we always say this i know but like these
are actually the best brownies you're
ever going to have they're gooey they're
chocolatey they're fudgy ugh they live
up to every expectation you think a
brownie should be
[Music]
we took all the tips and the tricks from
the internet from our old grandma's
recipes from places we'd worked to find
the best recipe that we could throw out
every other recipe that you have for
brownies this is the one you will use
going forward for the rest of your life
i'm not trying to like tutor on horn but
like beep beep you know
[Music]
all right guys as always prep your tin
you know what to do butter and parchment
so the first cooking job that i ever had
was working for a pastry chef and he
made these incredible brownies and when
you start working in kitchens they
always say like write down the recipes
because you're gonna forget them later
and of course i did not do that but
there are a few things that i remember
from his recipe that i really wanted to
incorporate into our brownie recipe
obviously good brownies need good
chocolate and the chocolate bar you want
to use is dealer's choice you can go for
something really mellow like a milk
chocolate bar or go into something
really really dark like an 80 dark
chocolate would work really well in here
we're gonna double up on the chocolate
so we're going to use cocoa powder as
well because we wanted a really rich
dark flavor in color we went with the
dutch processed you can use regular
cocoa powder here but we're always
looking for that intense flavor that
intense color the one on the left used
regular cocoa powder it's kind of drier
on top and almost like too dense and
fudgy on the bottom we're adding a
little bit of cocoa powder here we're
gonna add even more later espresso
powder just does a really great job of
enhancing any chocolate flavor in a
recipe
if you're worried about the caffeine you
can get a decaf powder as well it's not
going to taste like coffee or espresso
it's really just another flavor enhancer
when we add the hot melted butter to the
chocolate cocoa powder and espresso
powder it's going to help melt
everything down and dissolve which is
going to help keep our brownies really
fudgy later on
[Music]
sugars we have granulated sugar and then
when deciding between light brown and
dark brown the real difference here is
that dark brown has more molasses ergo
more flavor i don't even know what ergo
means
again just wanted to knock your socks
off with the flavor here and dark brown
was the right one for the job
and we're also going to add a bit of
salt as it brings out the flavor in any
baked good
so we're gonna have six eggs always
crack your eggs into a separate bowl in
case you get any shell
best way to remedy that is to use the
eggshell it breaks the surface tension
and is the easiest way to get eggshell
out of your eggs
you can start by adding one egg to the
sugar just so you don't make a huge mess
once you get it going though you can add
the rest of them no big deal you have to
be like super careful like you would for
a cake for instance so working for that
pastry chef one thing that he did with
his brownies was he would beat the
living crap out of the eggs and sugar
and really really incorporate tons of
air so much so that it would look like a
super thick pancake batter almost this
is what happens when you don't beat the
sugar and eggs kind of just falls really
flat right
the great thing about beating the eggs
in the sugar is you create like a really
solid foundation and you don't have to
use a chemical leavener
and then you're gonna pour in that
beautiful ganache that we made
oh my god
actually when we were shooting this
there is a crowd of people around us
because we couldn't get over how
insanely delicious this looked oh god i
just i can't believe we baked these i
honestly like i could have just eaten
the batter myself
i'm really upset that america can't get
on the metric system but like fine so if
we're gonna use cups always scoop and
level to make sure that we have the
right amount of flour if you just take
the cup straight into the flour it's
going to be denser than you need it to
be and you're going to sift the flour
and the cocoa powder into the mixture to
make sure we have no lumps and just make
sure that we're really quickly
incorporating it into the rest of the
batter
[Music]
and
fold
because we beat all that air in with the
eggs we don't want to totally deflate
that so just get the dry ingredients
incorporated as quickly as you can
pour the completed batter into your
prepped tin smooth it out to make sure
everything's pretty level
and into the oven it goes so these are
going to rise quite a bit after about 20
minutes we're going to take them out
this is like my favorite tip of the
whole recipe take the brownies out and
slam them on your kitchen counter it's
gonna crack the top as well as evens out
everything and you get a much more like
consistent texture this is the same
recipe the one on the left is not
whacked right whacked
at this point we're also going to add a
bit of sea salt optional but highly
recommended adds a little salty bite
sweet and salty always good
with a lot of baked goods you'll stick a
toothpick in and no batter remains then
you're good it's kind of not the case
with these brownies you will have a good
amount of kind of fudginess that comes
out on the toothpick trust us they've
been in there for like 45 minutes
they're definitely cooked through
they're just fudgy when they do cool
down they also will deflate quite a bit
it results in a really even texture all
throughout again i can't say fudgy
enough like i don't even like fudge
little known thing about me but these
brownies are like insane i need to cut
things nice they need to be like a good
perfect square it's so satisfying to see
like a perfectly cut batch of brownies
obviously
oh my gosh
a little tip too it's to clean your
knife after each cut so you'll see a
little bit of that fudginess comes off
they're fudgy but they're not dense
[Music]
and that is it i mean look at that
texture
look at it this is like your go-to
brownie batter it's amazing as is but
you can also mix in anything that you
want more chocolate chunks potato chips
pretzels this is like a phenomenal like
standard brownie recipe but feel free to
go crazy and mix in whatever you want
making brownies from scratch you know
there's other options out there that are
easier but it's like one of those
fundamental baked goods that doesn't
take a ton of technique but they also
kind of like go with everything in every
event you know what i mean like you have
a breakup brownies birthday brownies
like they kind of work for anything just
one of those like feel-good
crowd-pleasing desserts that's just like
always a win okay that's fine i'm just
gonna keep talking we're gonna leave it
it's gonna be fine you're funny claire
stop you're so [ __ ] you're so funny
beep
i guess